he says no what does he say up here I
will reduce reduce your planet let's
actress Goldie Hawn in the 1987 film
overboard proving it doesn't matter what
you read with your kids as long as you
are reading a survey found 20% of kids
aged 6 to 17 did not read any books at
all during the summer of 2018 that
percentage has been growing in 2016 it
was 15% now there's a new effort to help
parents install a love of reading in
their kids a book out today is called
how to raise a reader it shows the
benefits of reading at every stage of a
child's development from newborns to
teenagers pamela paul co-wrote the book
she's also the editor of the New York
Times Book Review Pamela welcome thanks
for being here thanks for having me you
say it's if you want to raise a reader
be a reader yeah it starts with you I
mean if you're sitting there saying to
your kid read a book while you're there
on your phone scrolling you're kind of
sending a mixed message so it's
important that reading be C&S something
that's part of the family culture that
your kids see you reading so you
choosing to read as opposed to just
watching TV or going on the iPhone or
whatever else and that reading becomes
something that's part of what your
family does and it's minutes free time
at what point do you and how hard you
push back against it but I don't want to
I don't like it I don't feel like it I'm
bored well that's the most important
thing really is that your school is in
charge of teaching your child how to
read what your job is as a parent is
teaching your child showing them how to
love to read so for every kid who says
he doesn't like reading or he thinks
it's boring
he probably just hasn't found the right
book and that's actually one of the best
parts of your book is that guide to you
go to the book store and in infinite
selection but you you have like five or
six at the end of each chapter for
age-appropriate reading for boys four
girls adventurers all different types
that's a great that's a great tip but to
start reading by the time they get to
the school preschool or kindergarten
it's too late right they should begin
since they are babies as they are
newborns actually you can start at least
reading to them and getting them to feel
there's toys now yeah that are like
books like made out of fabric with
Velcro and they can start getting the
feel for what a book is yes it's good
because they can't eat those books and
they but yeah it's really important even
when your child is an infant to read
aloud to them because they're absorbing
that and also it forges an emotional
connection you know you take your baby
you put him in your arms you hold him
you read aloud to him he might not
understand a single word but he's
feeling that connection that's becoming
part of a ritual and it gets you in the
habit to as a parent of sharing books
with your child and this is really I
mean this is really critical for kids I
mean my wife's a literary specialist we
talk about this a lot she always says to
me if you don't get your kids to read a
grade level by third grade there's a
real risk they may not graduate high
school because before that you're
learning to read after that you're
reading to learn yeah so you're actually
really helping your kids here you are
and the thing is is that you know kids
will learn to read eventually and that's
on the school you can do a lot to
support that but what's really important
is the home in the home is that books
become something that's a source of
pleasure because kids are feeling all of
that pressure at school they're anxious
parents are anxious about it like oh no
my child is you know two levels lower
than his friend and worst grade but
actually you know up into a certain
point really it's not about how fast or
how soon you learn to read it's about
creating a habit of reading and finding
pleasure in that because kids have so
many choices of what to do in their free
time right I mean you had that statistic
like they can play video games they can
go online they can watch TV they can be
outside they can they have so many
planned activities so they have to want
to read to choose yeah I was gonna ask
you about that about the technology how
do you compete with that when when they
are just glued to their phones and the
other part of the question is is it
valid to have them read books online
well it's not terrible you know reading
is reading but it is there is data that
shows there's research that shows that
kids absorb and retain information
better when it's read and print and
what's really interesting and this is a
good sign is that kids prefer to read
print books II
teenagers it's like they're on screens
all the time so they're just like us
they want to break from that [ __ ] outfit
your your book there with a little bell
that goes off every now and then
reminding people it's there maybe it
vibrates on the table pick me up I am a
pretty yes yes thank you very much
thanks Pamela
thanks for having how to race a reader
it's on sale now